[Musique]
savez-vous que le Toyota RAV4 on en vend
24 fois plus au Québec que des doses et
pourtant ça fait ce véhicule là sera pas
touché par notre plan oui c'est vrai le
Toyota RAV4 ne serait pas touché par la
taxe de 15 % sur l'achat de véhicules
neufs de Québec solidaire parce que ces
émissions polluantes sont plus faibles
que le seuil établi par la formation
politique en 2021 le modèle a en effet
été vendu 24 fois plus que le Dodge
caravane mais l'immense majorité des
fourgonnettes des camionnettes et des
véhicules utilitaires sport seraient
touchés on voudrait réduire de 5000 le
nombre d'employés de l'État on voudrait
fonctionner par attrition donc on
voudrait mais on veut réduire la taille
de l'État contrairement à Monsieur le
goût on va pas dire une chose pour faire
le contraire si on est élu c'est vrai
en 2018 la carte avait promis de
supprimer 5000 postes par attrition au
sein de la fonction publique mais le
nombre de fonctionnaires a plutôt grimpé
de près de 15% entre mars 2017 et mars
2021 pour atteindre plus de 55000
monsieur Legault il aime beaucoup ce
comparer à l'Ontario mais on a créé
trois fois moins il a créé trois fois
moins d'emplois que l'Ontario dans mais
c'est vrai monsieur Legault c'est vrai
mais elle ne dit pas tout l'Ontario a
créé 469 000 emplois depuis octobre 2018
c'est trois fois plus que le Québec qui
en a créé 156 000 pendant la même
période mais il ne faut pas oublier que
l'Ontario est beaucoup plus populaire
par ailleurs depuis que la kak est au
pouvoir le Québec a créé 17 % des
emplois au pays alors que la province
compte pour 23% de la population
canadienne
[Musique]
sur papier le taux de mortalité lié à la
covid-19 étant en effet plus élevé au
Québec qu'ailleurs au Canada mais ce nom
plusieurs experts c'est parce que la
province a mieux répertorié les
décennies à la covid-19 depuis le début
de la pandémie les données montrent que
la surmortalité a été plus faible au
Québec que dans l'ensemble du pays
laissant croire que moins de gens il
serait décédé de la covid
qu'on a triplé depuis quatre ans le
nombre de classes de maternelles 4 ans
c'est vrai mais il ne dit pas tout le
nombre de classes de maternelle 4 ans a
pratiquement quadruplé depuis 2018 pour
atteindre 1600 mais l'engagement de la
CAQ était d'ouvrir 5200 classes dans un
horizon de 5 ans un objectif qui a
finalement été réduit de moitié
ici Olivier Bachard Radio-Canada
Montréal